-Welcome back, everybody!
We're talking with
the one the only Will Ferrell,
who stars along Ryan Reynolds
in the new movie, "Spirited."
Will, welcome back.
Thank you so much
for being here.
-I love your beard, by the way.
-You do?
-How great does his beard look?
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's very flattering.
-I appreciate it.
It's been coming in.
-Yeah.
-I went through puberty
last month.
[ Laughter ]
-It's real, right?
-[ Laughs ]
It is real.
It was interesting.
We had --
Ryan Reynolds
was on Monday night,
and I said to him, I said,
"I look like --
this is like a Spirit
Halloween costume version
of Ryan Reynolds."
Yeah, yeah.
He's such a good-looking man.
But thank you.
-Yeah, he's gorgeous.
-I appreciate this.
I don't know
if I'm gonna keep it.
You think I should keep it?
-I think so, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I think so, yeah.
-Saying keep it.
-It frames your face.
I've seen your --
I've seen you with a beard.
-I've had a beard
every now and then.
-Your dad had a beard.
-Yeah, my dad has a beard.
-Yeah, he does.
He still -- He always did.
-Currently has a beard.
-Yes.
-That's his trademark look.
-Yeah. Beard.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, but you wouldn't --
would you --
You've had 'staches before.
-I've had 'stache--
I've had, like,
a thick mountain-man beard.
-Yeah.
Were you here -- Do you remember
when Forte grew --
-A lot of bugs -- collected
a lot of bugs in there.
-Do you remember when Forte
had a neck beard?
-Did he just -- He shaved
everything but kept this?
No, I don't remember that.
-It was great.
He tried to make it a thing.
He shaved --
-Did it catch on?
-No, no, no.
[ Laughter ]
Bud, you had a big weekend.
Over the weekend.
You have a soccer team,
first of all, with the LAFC.
-LAFC --
Los Angeles Football Club.
-Yeah, and -- and --
-And, yeah.
-You won the first
Major League Soccer Cup.
-Our first MLS Cup.
-You won!
-We won.
-Yes.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is a lot to celebrate.
-Yeah.
-But this is --
It was very exciting.
It was down to a penalty, right?
-Went to overtime,
and we tied it up in the --
I don't know --
last minute of the overtime.
Then it went
to the penalty kicks.
-How fun is this?
-And it was just crazy.
-We have a clip of you
celebrating with the trophy.
Take a look at this thing here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Drinking from a cup.
-I mean, come on.
What --
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a big deal
-And we had so many --
We had Magic Johnson was there,
Sia was there.
We have all this
wonderful family.
Justin Bieber was there.
-No way.
Yeah.
-Wait. What?
-Slay? Slay?
-Slay?
-What'd you say?
-Slay.
-Slay?
-Oh, it sounded like, "Baah!"
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Well --
-Like, is that a thing?
When you say Justin Bieber,
people go, "Baah!"
-No.
[ Laughter ]
-He has a lot of, yeah, fans.
-A ghost sheep.
-Yeah, a ghost -- yeah.
Well, we invite every --
We are allowed to invite
livestock to the show now.
-Oh, that's great.
-It's a new thing we're doing.
2022 we started this thing.
-I love it.
-And, yeah,
so animals love the show.
-This show's so innovative.
-Yeah.
I mean, we're just --
not just for humans, you know?
-Yeah.
-We're for everybody,
so shout-out
to all the sheep out there.
-Yep.
[ Cheering ]
-I noticed there's a very rare
California condor
in the back row.
[ Laughter ]
There's only, like,
seven alive in the world.
Yeah.
-There any cows out there?
[ Scattered mooing ]
-Couple over there.
Couple over there.
-Do we have any Bengal tigers?
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my --
-No Be-- No Bengal tigers.
-No, no, I heard a baby --
-I heard a baby Bengal tiger.
[ Imitating weak growl ]
-Waking up.
Yeah, just taking a nap.
They're waking up.
[ Both growling weakly ]
They're taking a nap.
-So cute, little baby Bengal.
-Love a baby Bengal, man.
[ Laughter ]
-God, I wish we could
hold that baby Bengal.
-No.
-No, okay.
Never mind.
-Where's the baby Bengal tiger?
I'll go find it.
I'll go find --
[ Scattered cheers ]
Where is that baby Bengal tiger?
Come here, I hear you.
I found it.
Hey, how you doing?
Come here.
How you doing?
Come on over.
Be careful.
Hey, be careful.
-Oh.
-This is, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Want to sit on his lap?
-Nice to meet you.
-Sit on his lap, I guess.
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
-Oh, all right.
Slippery.
Rawr!
-Rawr.
-How --
-[ Hissing ]
[ Laughter ]
[ Growls ]
-Ooh!
-How old is this, tiger, Will?
-Uh...
3 months old.
-Oh, my goodness.
-Can I borrow one of your pens?
They love objects like this.
They --
-Mreow! Mrow!
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. All right.
-This is how they learn to hunt.
-Be careful.
-[ Hissing ]
-Oh, be careful, be careful!
Be careful, be careful,
be careful.
All right.
-Oh! Whoa.
-Be careful.
[ Laughter ]
-He --
-Be good.
-He's gonna -- He's gonna
get to be much bigger.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now, did you have him on set?
Well, I guess
he's only 3 months, so I mean...
-He travels with me.
-He does travel with --
-Yeah.
-And how long have you --
And he travels
to every premiere?
-Every movie premiere.
Uh, every family holiday.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my goodness.
-But he loves talk shows.
-You do?
-I do, I do.
-You love coming to New York?
Oh, and you --
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-You speak English?
-He does.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my --
Oh, my God.
-Yeah.
-Wow, that's amazing.
You taught him that.
That's amazing.
-The scientific community
is going crazy over this guy.
-They're going --
-They're going nuts.
-This is --
-He's, like, one of a kind.
-This is absolutely something
I've never seen before.
-Because I've had so many
Bengal tigers,
and none of them
could speak English.
[ Laughter ]
And this is the first one.
-Is the better for you
'cause you get to communicate
with other humans?
-Yeah. Yeah.
I mean, they like it when I do
the -- [ hisses ] -- thing.
-Yeah.
-But, usually, I mean,
they don't get what I mean.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, I do the -- [ hisses ] --
and they're just like,
"That's so cute," but...
-Yeah, yeah.
It means -- But it means,
"I want to rip your face off."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Sometimes.
-So you speak English,
but it also, you have
kind of an accent, as well.
-I do. I do.
Yeah, it's a German accent.
-German, yeah.
-So it's a German --
-I spoke -- I taught him English
in a German accent.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You think -- You think teaching
in English would be enough.
-You would think,
but I wanted it to be distinct.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, but just speaking English
would make him rare enough.
-Yeah, I just -- you know,
I just didn't know
how many other baby
Bengal tigers knew English.
And I thought, "Well,
if this becomes a thing,
at least my guy speaks
with a German accent."
-Yeah. Does your tiger
also speak German?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yes, the tiger speaks German.
[ Laughter ]
-Honestly, this is --
-And he does, too.
-I do, too, yeah.
-Oh, you do?
Could you say something?
-Yeah, um...
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
-You get embarrassed?
You get embarrassed?
-Uh...
-Very quiet.
-Der Spiegel.
-Der Spiegel, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Beautifully said.
Beautifully said.
-Yeah. Well, you want
to let him go back --
-Should we release you?
Okay. Run, run, run!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-He made it.
♪♪
-That's amazing.
-Yeah.
-Thank you for bring--
Thank you for bringing him.
-I mean...
To -- To see them in the wild
is one thing,
but to really hold them
up close...
-That's something
I'll never forget.
I've never been that close
to a Bengal tiger.
Can we talk about "Spirited"?
-Uh...
-Your movie?
[ Laughter ]
Let's talk about your film.
That's just amazing.
That was fantastic.
But "Spirited" is --
I love this movie.
I love it.
Ryan Reynolds.
-It's a musical.
-Yes.
-Yeah.
-Singing and dancing in this.
-A reimagining of
"A Christmas Carol."
-I like the plot, by the way.
I love it.
It's like the idea of
the Ghost of Christmas Present,
but his -- his life.
-Right.
The viewpoint of the ghost world
and how, every year,
they pick a Scrooge to haunt,
but my character,
Christmas Present, is having
kind of a crisis of faith
and wondering,
"God, we pick, you know,
a turd out every year
and try to convert them."
-Yeah.
-"But is it really
doing any good?
And why are we even
doing this anymore?"
-"What is the point
of what we're doing?"
-That's kind of
the thrust of the movie.
-It's so funny. And by the way,
who did the music?
-Pasek and Paul who --
-"La La Land."
-"The Greatest Showman."
-"Greatest Showman."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-They are brilliant.
Every song is...
-Yeah.
-...so catchy, so funny.
-But we really had to sing.
It wasn't like
singing in a sketch
or, you know...
-Doing a bit.
-It was -- It was earnest,
you know,
singing in a meaningful way.
And so had to do
all this training
and seven weeks
of rehearsals, and...
But you -- I mean, Jimmy,
you obviously sing a lot...
-Yeah.
-...in your stuff.
Do you do vocal training at all?
That's what I found fascinating,
some of the...
-Oh.
-Did you ever -- did you ever --
Did you --
Do you do warm-up stuff at all?
-No.
-Did you ever do lion's pose?
-No. What's that?
-Lion's pose.
You start here.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
-Uh-huh.
-And then bring it back.
-Mm-hmm.
-And then again.
[ Laughter ]
And then bring it back.
Mm-hmm.
Then another lion's pose.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm sorry, the Bengal tiger's
getting jealous right now.
I'm sorry, he's just --
[ Laughter ]
He can see --
I heard a word in German.
-He wants me to call it
tiger's pose, but it's not.
It's the lion's pose.
-It's the lion's pose,
That's how -- And you do that
for vocal warm-up?
-That stretches
the back of your mouth.
And, uh, uh...
Oh, here's another good one
I would do.
♪ Popcorn, peanuts ♪
♪ Get it while it's hot ♪
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Popcorn, peanuts ♪
♪ Get 'em while they're hot ♪
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
[ Clenched voice ] I can feel it
doing something to my voice.
[ Laughter ]
-That's my desired effect.
Yum --
-[ Chuckles ]
-Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum,
yum, yum.
-Yum, yum, yum, yum,
yum, yum, yum.
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum,
yum, yum.
-And that opens everything up.
-Opens everything up.
This is great tips.
We're all professional singers
now after this tonight, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Can we -- Can we show everyone
a clip from the movie?
-Yeah, please.
-Here's Will Ferrell
in "Spirited."
Take a look at this.
-Jacob, please,
I can't explain it,
but if I could just change
this guy, maybe I'll --
-What?
-Maybe you'll what?
[ Guitar strumming
in background ]
Oh, no, no.
There's no need
for a whole big number yet.
No, no spotlight.
-Gary, kill the spot--
-♪ Every day I wake up ♪
♪ With a single dream ♪
♪ Runnin' through my head ♪
-Look, I have another meeting
I'm actually late for.
-♪ To throw a tiny stone
into a mighty stream ♪
♪ And watch the ripples
as they spread ♪
-Redeeming an unredeemable
is nearly impossible.
But if you promise
to stop singing,
you can have your part.
-Oh. Really?
Great.
Thank you.
That's --
That's quite reasonable.
-Yes!
Will Ferrell, everybody!
"Spirited" opens in theaters
on Friday,
and it's on Apple TV+
November 18th.